foreign
we are regularly asked as evolutionary
biologists what is the explanation for
male nipples and frankly I love the
question
many I will I would just say that um I
as a female evolutionary biologist I've
been asked that question probably less
than five times and you have been asked
that question a lot in part because you
say like you you know that you think
about it and you have an idea and all
this but um I do believe that this is
more likely to be a question asked well
a man with nipples
it's liable to be asked a lot of a man
without nipples but they don't exist so
we can't test that hypothesis it exists
the alternative hypothesis and you know
it I do
um all right but let's uh let us so
let's just say uh many in fact I think
all evolutionary biologists have
pondered this question at some point and
it's a wonderful one which intersects
very well
with a concept
I don't want to drag people too deep
into the weeds but yes you do decades
ago uh I came up with an Adaptive test a
test to see whether a particular feature
of organisms should be presumed to be a
product of adaptive Evolution or not and
the reason I came up with that was not
because this wasn't obvious I thought it
was obvious but because there was a
battle in evolutionary biology over the
question of whether evolutionary
biologists were leaping the conclusions
imagining that various features of
organisms were the result of adaptation
when maybe you know there are lots of
other evolutionary processes could it
perhaps be the result
of drift or whatever so anyway I came up
with a test to free myself from that
stupid question which disrupts
everything if you let it get away from
you and the test it basically you just
uh make a lot of arm gestures while you
describe it you want me to do a lot of
arm away like you should okay
um the test involves it's it's a
conservative test it will miss some
things that are actually the result of
adaptive Evolution and it is not a
hundred percent conclusive it will
lead you to the correct presumption if
you apply the test correctly and it is
conservative uh in a it's got a
Fail-Safe in it so it basically asks
whether several characteristics can be
found inside of a particular trait so
let's say we're talking about the um I
should have gotten a
image for this but there is a an extinct
reptile a a dinosaur Epoch reptile
called a polycosaur
which has a sale on its back this was a
clay there were lots of different
follicular sores but anyway Heather will
bring up a picture of a polycosaur
so these animals had a sale on their
back we don't know what the sale was for
because there are no polycosaurs that we
can observe or you know bring to the
laboratory or anything like that so we
are left with this structure and no
ability to run a test in the present on
what it does
so my point is yeah it's true that we
don't know what it what what it does one
example of something it might do it
might be a solar panel that allows these
animals to warm their blood by turning
that sail towards the Sun but again we
can't observe them so we don't know but
my point is that question the mystery
surrounding what the sale on the back of
a plicosaur does is not the same
question as whether or not it is the
product of adaptive Evolution obviously
it's the product of adaptive Evolution
and the test to show that this is the
the correct presumption is does it
involve high levels of complexity
biology adaptive evolution is the only
process that creates high levels of
complexity
so is this complex yes there will have
been a developmental pathway that has
produced this polecosaur
application sale
um you know it has a structure it has
bones it has skin all of these things
that we can still detect in the fossils
so it has complexity it has an expense
it's made out of materials right
materials that could be redirected
materials and energy that could be
redirected to something else that would
enhance the fitness of the creature and
it persists over evolutionary time right
complex it has an expense and it
persists of evolutionary time and my
point is
if it were not
producing a benefit to that organism
that exceeds that cost than over
evolutionary time it would be eliminated
right and we wouldn't see it instead
what we saw is a whole clade of
organisms different species that had
these things which says that some
organism that had less of one uh was not
out competing those that had had more of
them
so here's the reason that I like this
nipple question
the nipple question passes the male
nipple question passes the Adaptive test
right
it's not hugely expensive but it is an
expense nipples are made out of material
that material does not have an obvious
benefit in males but there's a
complexity to it that material and
energy that goes into producing a male
nipple could be redirected into other
Fitness enhancing behaviors or
structures and so what the hell is going
on given that male nipples are not
useful in the feeding of Offspring why
would selection not have economized
these things out of existence long ago
now here's the hypothesis which I I have
come to believe very strongly is likely
to be true but needs a test
the hypothesis is that if you have a
mechanism if you built into human beings
or to uh
any
mammal if you built in a mechanism in
ethereum that would remove nipples when
the male physiology program had been
triggered anytime something was going to
be a male you Econo economized away the
nipples then what you've got is a
mechanism that turns nipples off
once you've got a mechanism that turns
nipples off a it can go wrong
occasionally a female who is otherwise
reproductively capable will lack nipples
and her children will presumably starve
um and B it creates a target for some
let's say plant that you're eating to
disrupt if it wants if it sees you as a
parasite and uh is looking to reduce the
level of parasitism can it disrupt that
pathway now that that pathway exists so
the hypothesis is that the pathway is so
dangerous where milk production is
essential to the raising of offspring
that
selection has built in a resistance to
economizing it away
so that no female is born without
nipples and therefore those Offspring
Don't Starve for the lack of the ability
to feed them early in in childhood
now again this is a hypothesis it is not
it has not survived a test so far as I
am aware
I will say a valid scientific hypothesis
requires a
test it at least needs to be testable in
principle hopefully in practice but at
least in principle to be a valid
hypothesis something like let's say oh I
don't know String Theory which doesn't
provide a mechanism for testing it is
not even not only is it not a theory
it's not even a hypothesis right it
becomes a hypothesis at which it makes a
test so in this case there may be better
tests I may come up with something more
elegant and easier to accomplish but I
would say the correct test that I spot
is if it is true that selection has
actively protected nipples from being
removed in males because of the danger
that it would pose in females to have
such a pathway
then we will find
that there is a protective mechanism in
other words the degree to which
different genes are exposed to
experimentation evolutionary
experimentation varies there are some
genes that are highly experimental
because they're involved in arms races
and there are other genes that are very
conservative because disrupting them
creates a Cascade of bad effects I would
argue that we will find that the genes
involved in the production of nipples
have been given uh that protective
characteristic that prevents
experimentation with their elimination
developmentally and that that is why we
see them right and in fact that would be
the Adaptive feature right the nipples
would be a manifestation of that
adaptation which has moved nipples out
of the experimental category into a
highly conserved category of the genome
and served it's not it's not exactly a
question of low evolvability but it's a
it's about
um a sort of a separate kind of uh
conservatism around what could be
changed it's it's hard to operationalize
them in part because we don't there's so
many possible mechanisms by which that
might happen but um the prediction
then that you are making for your
hypothesis is that there will be
something to be to be specified upon
discovery
um that is uh that is
producing lower rates of change in those
genes than in adjacent other otherwise
comparable genes that do something else
yeah I wouldn't say adjacent because one
of the things that happens is that genes
have moved around the genome to protect
them from experimentation I would point
out though in thinking about this this
morning this is what I'm really arguing
for is the inverse of what I have
elsewhere called an Explorer mode right
Explorer modes are places where
Evolution looks around design space for
Solutions at a um in a direct way this
is a place where such experimentation is
reduced and it creates a kind of genetic
sacredness or uh some other kind it
creates a you know a taboo around
genetic experimentation but in any case
that's the basic hypothesis
[Music]
thank you